(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Located in Yemen is a palace
that appears to have been carved
from the rock that it sits on.
However, this man-made wonder
was once just a simple summer home.
Just 10 miles away from
Yemen's capital city of Sanaʽa
is Dar al-Hajar, otherwise
known as Imam's Rock Palace.
In the early days of Yemen's history,
the country was led by the Imam,
the Islamic spiritual leader,
rather than a king or president.
The Rock Palace was built in the 1930s
by Imam Yahya as his summer residence.
However, it is believed to have been
built over an older palace.
The residence is five stories
high, has several balconies
and its own water supply from a deep well.
It is seen as an example of
traditional Yemen architecture
due to the patterned
windows, earth-tone coloring
and protruding exterior decorations.
While tourism in this region
is limited due to conflict,
this palace is both a sanctuary for locals
and an example of the
man-made beauty of Yemen.